[Music]
hey guys this is vic and today we're
going to be testing out four famous
celebrity pasta recipes to find out
which one is actually the best on
today's lineup we have meghan markle
robert pattinson caitlyn jenner and a
fun one from rihanna i measured out all
the ingredients exactly as each recipe
stated and i got three pasta lovers to
pick their favorite recipe so which
celebrity has the best pasta recipe
let's get started first up is her royal
highness meghan markle she starts off by
creating what she calls her filthy sexy
mush a zucchini based sauce boiled for
four hours
she boils up her rigatoni
adds lemon juice red chili flakes
parmesan cheese and mixes it all
together until the pasta is evenly
coated there you have it meghan markle's
pasta
there doesn't seem to be a ton of
ingredients this looks kind of
this looks a little dry but really
interesting these are probably
vegetables yeah maybe it's on the
healthier side
it's not as bad as it looks it's got a
little bit of a kick it wouldn't be my
first choice i think it's a little bland
not the most flavorful i'd say but like
it's pretty good out of one or ten i
would give it like a fair six this one's
okay not my fave next up is caitlyn
jenner she starts by boiling her pasta
she chops up some peppers and throws
them in a pan with a little oil until
they get tender
she then adds hot italian sausage and
breaks it up into little bite-sized
pieces she stirs garlic red pepper
flakes and adds a pepper mixture basil
parsley and parmesan cheese mixes it
together and serves it topping it off
with a little parmesan and there you
have it caitlyn jenner's celsius and
pepper pasta i love the color in the mix
this looks like something i'm into we
got some veggies we got some meat
those are like it's a bit greasy that's
the only thing that i was saying this
looks like something that i could order
at a restaurant the meatball or sausage
situation is really well done it has a
little bit of a spice i would see myself
making this at home next up we have
robert pattinson's picolini cuccino or
little pillow in italian robert starts
cooking his pasta in the microwave for
about 10 minutes next he makes a
bowl-shaped mold out of aluminum foil he
puts in crushed corn flakes sugar cheese
tomato sauce more sugar than dumps in
the cooked pasta he tops it off with his
pc branded bun and puts it in the oven
for 10 minutes to melt the ingredients
together a little different but there
you have it robert pattinson's piccolini
cucino i like how this looks already are
these corn flakes not used to that
really being in there this looks pretty
good
okay um take all that back this is
really good this is like definitely
comfort food you got your cheese you got
your sugar you got tons of carbs i need
to know who made this we need to have a
chat i love the tomato sauce and there's
cheese i didn't expect to like it
because there's a lot going on but yeah
i'd eat this i could see like flakes of
sugar at the bottom of my bowl this is
so sad this reminds me of a lasagna it's
very homemade style i like it a lot
finally the recipe you've all been
waiting for rihanna's spicy chicken
pasta she starts by cooking her pasta
shells then she chops up onion garlic
peppers and green onions tossing them in
a pan with a little olive oil once the
veggies are tender she throws her
marinated chicken and cooks until the
chicken is through
she builds her pasta by adding hot sauce
mustard butter the chicken pepper mix
and a plate of cheese and stirs until
combined there you have it rihanna's
spicy chicken pasta this looks fancy it
looks like it's curry style we're seeing
some variety of meat and veggie mmm i
like there's a little kick the flavor is
good it's strong i wish it were like a
little more saucy but it's good i can
see myself eating this without feeling
guilty the chicken's more flavorful than
the noodles themselves still overall
feels like a fancy-ish meal
so which celebrity has the best pasta
recipe let's find out out of these four
celebrity pasta recipes my favorite
would have to be number two it had a
really nice kick it was really flavorful
the meat was well seasoned in flavor
there was really good veggies in there
kaitlyn
girl i'm really intrigued by number
three
so much going on with the corn flakes
with the cheese with the tomato with the
bun you got the sweet you got the savory
it really has all of the comfort food
flavors what
and even though he makes pasta out of
the four celebrity dishes that i tried
my favorite has to be the third dish
that bread sold me along with that pasta
sauce
really that's his recipe
there you have it robert pattinson has
the best pasta recipe
which recipe should we try next leave a
comment below
[Music]
you